he walks into my room super serious and
he walks in he goes
hey
I said what's up he goes humor
so what's going on he goes no no no no
no
step outside
now I'll tell you what I thought was
happening
what I thought was happening is I had
thought he hit that age that every man
hits where they look at their dad that
first time and they think
don't beat the [__] out of this dude
what
none not everybody does it but everybody
looks at their dad at least once like oh
tell me to take out the trash again
so we're walking outside I'm tightening
up my shoelaces I'm like oh it's [__]
on okay here we go
and I'm planning on just poking him in
the neck once really hard to slow him
down and [__] you know because he's
bigger than me I need to slow him down
he's a big dude
and uh we get outside and he goes
touch the boo
and I said yeah what do you think he
goes well I'm definitely going to try to
do that again
so now he did try to fight me and I grew
up with three older brothers we all
wrestled or fought my dad at least once
growing up anybody in here wrestle or
fight their dad
how old were you man how old 12 not a
lot of muscle tone on a 12 year old 12
huh how'd that go for you yeah
you know what you learned early on as a
young man is that your dad takes it way
more seriously than you do
you right because you're like I'm gonna
mess with the old man he's like you're
like what the [__]
yeah man Listen by the way I asked some
dude last week I go how old were you
when you fight your dad he goes 30. I
was like holy [__]
that's just beating up an old man at
that point in time right
but you know what he said he goes yeah
well it's the first time I thought I had
a shot so
and I'm not mad at him you're going
where you think you've got your shot you
know but I remember when my oldest
brother the first time he decided he was
going to fight my dad right so me and my
other two brothers are in my room were
all under the age of 10 I'm probably
like six my oldest brother's probably
16. and he walks into the room super
serious right he walks in he's like
I'm fighting dad today
and I'm six I'm like
you find dad they're trying to find dad
you guys got my back and we were all
like
you guys you guys ready for some new
rules I'm like yeah
he goes what do you want I'm like I want
to eat cereal for dinner he's like you
got it I'm like [__] that guy yeah
oh he was riling us up God I thought
there was gonna be a regime change
everybody I needed to be on the right
side of that [__] you know he had us
riled up I was grabbing pictures of my
dad off the wall like
we're downstairs following him he's like
you guys ready like yeah we're ready you
guys get my back we got your back
we get outside my dad's in the patio and
he's smoking a cigar he's sitting down
my brother walks out and he goes we're
fighting the nail man
my dad stands up and he goes okay
now
hindsight being what it is
my dad's confidence
should have been a bit of a red flag for
my brother
dude didn't even take the cigar out of
his [__] mouth
he knew he wasn't getting hit you know
what I mean like if you go to a fight
and one of the guys has a cigar in his
mouth that's the [__] winner that guy
is like I am confident as [__]
so my brother goes and let me tell you
something and before he could get
another word
out of his [__] mouth my dad
kicked him in the nuts so hard
and he fell on the ground right
my dad walks up to him and goes you know
you shouldn't talk when you fight right
and walked in the house like a [__]
gangster
and we all walk past them like yeah
[Applause]
well I'm not hanging outside with a
loser I'm going inside for the winter
like I'm not stupid you know
but he did try to fight me
so I'm walking into the kitchen he's
walking out and he leans his shoulder
into me
and I go uh
did you just lean your shoulder into me
and he goes maybe you should watch where
you're going
and I started to laugh I go I'm sorry
are you starting to fight with me and he
goes uh yeah not that it's gonna be much
of a fight
and I was like all right man front lawn
right now let's go and he goes no no not
now like three weeks I'm like three who
are you [__] Rocky what do you mean
three weeks
you gotta go turn some tires over and
[__] like what
he goes I gotta go look up some videos
online I'm like oh okay
now listen outwardly when he said three
weeks I was mocking him but on the
inside when he said three weeks I was
like you
because I'm at an age where I pull
muscles and I pull muscles doing [__]
that I shouldn't pull a muscle doing
like not too long ago I pulled a muscle
in my right shoulder
wiping my ass
I went back too quick and I didn't tuck
my core it's all core nowadays I don't
[__] know
but I went back too quick and all my
wife heard when she walked by the door
was oh no
guys listen guys if I get a stretch
before I [__] you can kill me tonight
you know like if you walk into the
bathroom later and I'm like this and
you're like
what are you doing man I'm getting ready
to poop like you can
I don't need to come out of the bathroom
you can kill me in there
now here's the deal by the way you
couldn't do what my dad did now
this is this is definitely something
that you could not get away with now we
have raised a different generation of
kids you guys know that right we have
raised a generation of spoiled entitled
[__] you understand that right
now we can clap all you want but you
know whose fault it is
yeah they didn't raise themselves guys
it's our fault and we've coddled them to
the point or that it's ridiculous do you
know that in a lot of states in our
great country they've outlawed dodgeball
do you know why because they say it
humiliates the children Round of
Applause by the way that's ironically
why we played the [__] game to begin
with
[Applause]
right I was like who are we making cry
today right
Applause people remember playing
dodgeball
crap and if I said after the show we're
going to clear out the tables and play
some dodgeball who would play some
dodgeball
because we all have that shared
experience right everybody in here
remembers what that Red Rubber tastes
like on your lips right and your eyes
are watering your nose starts to run you
try to get off the court
nine other balls hit you and you're like
I'm not already [__] [__]
they'll never have that experience will
they
so I called my dad on the phone
because I know my son wants to fight me
I call him on the phone I'm like hey man
we all fought you right he goes yeah
and I said I seem to remember you being
a little more violent than you needed to
be
and he said no yeah you remember
correctly
and I said why why why why and he goes
listen man he wants to win right I said
yeah he said you have to win you have to
win because if you don't win the power
changes at your house and then you try
to tell him to take out the trash
tomorrow he's gonna slap you in the face
and be like you take the trash out [__]
don't make me [__] you up again
and I was like oh my God he said this is
how and then you said something by the
way that I will never forget
I go I have to win he said Josh even if
somebody ends up calling the police
you have to win and I was like
oh
[Applause]
now listen I'm not a violent dude my dad
was more Adept at that and now I did
have three older brothers so I am really
good at mental torture
so I was like that's kind of where I'll
lean on so I hang up the phone and I
turn around and my wife is there and she
looks right at me she goes
are you fighting Jacob
and I said no no no I'm not gonna fight
him it's gonna be something we're gonna
do something in the front lawn but it's
not gonna be like a fight
foreign
why don't you just tell them that you're
the grown-up and he's the kid
and that's it he does what you say and
I'm like nah
I said that's not gonna work and she
said why I said I'm not sure if you were
there but he basically slapped me in the
face with his dick in the kitchen like
there's only one response she goes I
don't like it I said I'm not saying it's
the right response I'm just saying it's
the only one that I know do you know she
said I don't think this is a good idea
and then I maybe got a little too cocky
and I said
I'll let you know when I have a bad idea
and she was like oh okay
you're gonna let me know and I said yeah
and she goes oh okay so I know I gotta
start torturing my son right I call my
brother on the phone because I'm like
you guys tortured me endlessly what
should I do and he said what do you mean
all you talked about growing up was I
wish I had a little brother so I could
do to him what you guys did to me he
goes now is your chance nobody gets to
go back and do that and I was like you
know you're you're right this is quite
an opportunity
and he said yeah man do you want me to
send you over the list
and I go
what list he goes or the list of things
that we had that we used to do to you
and I said
why do you still have the list
and he was like you never know do you
and I don't know so he sends a list over
right and I'm looking at it and he said
Just remember the most important thing
is to start small and go up from there
so this all started on a Sunday now
listen he wants three weeks I don't want
to give him a full three weeks I want to
get this I want to get him so mad my son
that he wants to fight at the end of the
week I need to get him so mad because
that's the only chance I have of beating
him right so my brother's like start
slow like okay so Sunday night when my
son is sleeping I took all of his
underwear out of his drawer
and I replaced it with panties with the
days of the week on
[Applause]
so when he woke up the next morning I'm
cooking breakfast and I hear from the
other room I hear what
what is this
hey these aren't my underwear
these aren't my underwear
and I just yelled back hey just put your
Mondays on Sunshine and come on out for
some breakfast
and he was like I'm gonna fight you so
hard and I was like don't say that don't
say that don't say that we're I hope
you're not fighting me hard I don't feel
too bad what I'm doing to them we're at
day three back checking in back in the
fight and I'm starting to up my battle a
little bit and I started to do something
my parents my brother did to me that I
hated I put Vaseline in basically every
pocket that he had jacket pocket pant
pocket anything oh that will drive you
slowly crazy right and I could hear him
go oh I'm gonna fight
and then it was funny because my wife
calls me into the bedroom and she goes
you come in here hang on sure and I look
on the mirror in written in Vaseline on
the mirror
I can't wait to fight you
and she goes
you happy with yourself and I go yeah
actually I'm pretty happy I go he just
wrote a Death Wish when Vaseline he's
ready to snap like he's I'm not gonna
have to wait 12 days he's ready to go
right now right and by the way I don't
want anyone thing feeling bad for them
about things that I do to them they get
me just as much do you understand that
like that's part of the thing in our
family like funny is funny funny wins
and they ski I scare really easily and
my daughter scared me because I also
smoke a lot of weed and uh
here
and so my daughter scared me one time
she hid in the front yard so they know
that I come home High every now and then
and um
she was waiting in the front yard in a
long white flowy gown and a scream mask
I walked into the yard and she was like
and I jazz hand when I get scared
I make a laugh and I jazz hand there's
like a million videos they have of me
going like this
so [__] them they get everything they
get everything
but I knew my son was getting ready to
lose his mind right
so I started to step up my game and I
did something to him that my brothers
did to me that used to drive me crazy
they used to put the basket sauce on my
fingertips when I was sleeping
well because the first thing you do when
you wake up in the morning is what
you go pee
anybody who's ever touched a jalapeno
and then gone to the bathroom
yeah that's not fun you know so I put
the basketball sauce on his fingertips
and I just wait
I wait five in the morning I get up I
sit in the living room and I hear him go
to the bathroom and then he walks he
walks into the living room
[Applause]
[Music]
and he goes
hey
I said hey he goes
what does it mean
what
if your penis is on fire
[Applause]
it could mean a lot of things so you're
like what like what like what like what
I said well you could have a virus and
why don't you do that if you have a
virus what do you do I'm all over they
take a needle
you stick it in the base of your penis
what a penis shot I don't want one of
those
what else what else what other what is
there any other option I go well yeah I
said with it you could have like a
bacterial infection oh okay what is that
what does that mean how do they fix that
I go well they take a needle
stick it in the basement oh no need a
shot well I don't want to is there any
option besides paint a shot I I don't I
go there's a one the third one but it's
so rare like
it never happens he's like what is it
I'm like it just doesn't happen he goes
what is it is it a Peter shot him no he
was telling me what it is
like okay I go it's possible but it
never happens but it's possible
it's somebody snuck into your room and
put Tabasco sauce on your fingertips
when you're sleeping
[Laughter]
[Applause]
sleeping and he was like I'm gonna fight
you so hard I'm like don't say that
don't say that
so I'm like listen
right now we're at the house
we're at day five and he's ready to snap
after the Vaseline I know he's ready to
snap so I do the thing to him that my
brothers did to me that made me snap the
quickest they used to lock me in my
bathroom
oh yeah for hours
now I wasn't gonna lock him in for hours
just like an hour and a half something
like that
and so when he's in the bathroom I take
some rope and I tie it to the handle and
I tie the other part of the Rope to the
doorbell tore the door
of the door handle and uh
I just sit and I wait
and I hear the toilet flush
and then I just hear the door handle
and I get a text
I'm locked in the bathroom
so I sent him a text back
I know
thank you
[Applause]
and then it was just like in a horror
movie all from the inside of the
bathroom all I heard is are you out
there
[Applause]
let's be out of here right now or I'll
break the door down
and I pick up my phone I'm like break it
down has anyone in here ever seen
someone try to break down the door
some funny [__] the first time I saw it
I was in college and my buddy was like
I'm beating the [__] out of this guy and
I go let's go and he goes to his house
and the door was locked and he was like
I'm breaking in I go break in and my
buddy went and his little hip went
because it's a [__] door everybody
that's why they put it up there so you
can't walk in and out all wheely-nilly
you can break down a door you watch too
much Law and Order that's all I'm saying
the door
so he goes I'm gonna break it down and
the reason I have my camera up guys is
because I'm gonna film it because I
already have my wife and I have a video
that's seven and a half minutes long of
dumb [__] that he's done that we're
gonna play at his wedding
so I'm like this is gonna be a perfect
video now guys I have on that video 90
seconds of the best thing you've ever
seen in your life funny are there
anything you ever seen on YouTube
funnier than anything you've ever seen
in a movie TV show anything my son such
an excitable just loving life person
even as a young young young boy he
rushed through [__] so I have 90 seconds
of a video because we were playing in
the living room and he went to the
bathroom and when he ran out he was not
careful in the bathroom and he had a
little bit of [__] on his earlobe
I have a 90 second video of him doing
this
hey you want to play what is that
[Applause]
you guys saw five seconds of it I have
85 more seconds of Dutch it's the best
thing I've ever seen in my life whenever
I'm in a bad mood I'm like throwing the
tape like that is the best thing I've
ever seen
so I have it up like this right and I'm
ready because I know what's gonna happen
he goes I'm breaking it down I go do it
there's one
two
three and all I hear is
silence
it's quiet for like two three minutes
and then
and then he goes he goes
I'm pretty sure this is child abuse
[Applause]
all right
and I said yeah which part he was like
dig all of it
silence for like another three minutes
then he said something laugh so hard I
had to leave the room
I just hear from the bathroom
I'm hungry
ah so I come back in the room and this
is what I knew he started to crack he
goes Dad Dad listen listen
if you crack the door and slip in a
sandwich
I promise not to try to get out I'm like
I'll [__] Stockholm syndrome and said
anyway this dude
negotiated with his captors and stuff
you know
I go I can't do that man he's like oh
and this one I knew he was ready to
fight I just heard him starting to
mumble to himself
oh
and then he said this he goes well when
I get out of here I'm just gonna shake
him and I was like
[__] I've never been so mad where I'm
like I'm just gonna shake a [__] out of
that I was like oh he's ready to fight I
go you ready to come out man he goes
yeah I'm ready
and I go okay and I open the door you've
never seen a bull come out of a shoot at
a rodeo where all their muscles are
moving at once and he's come out he's
like I'm gonna bite you so hard and like
are you ready he goes I'm ready I go
let's go he goes not yet I gotta change
into my fight clothes I'm like
what's that
so I go out in the hallway and I see my
wife Beth and she's like
listen
you sure you still want to fight him I
go he just he was just talking about
shaking somebody so he's gonna fight
somebody today so might as well be me
and she said this is nothing good is
going to come out of this nothing good
even if you win nothing good comes out
of this she said I really think it's a
bad idea and I said what did I tell you
about that
I'll let you know when I have a bad idea
[Applause]
she was like okay and I go just do me a
favor
my phone in the
and the way to go out
wedding video over me pinning him right
and she goes okay so I walk outside and
when I walk outside guys I'm pretty
happy with myself for a couple of
reasons one I didn't have to get is
violent as my dad did to get him this
mad right and two
look whatever you all think about it
nobody in here remembers the stories
about when you were a kid how many times
your mom cut the crust off your sandwich
you don't remember the nice stuff you
were like you remember when [__]
Tommy fell off the roof do you know what
I mean those are the stories you tell
and I know this is a story he's gonna
tell this is a memory we're gonna share
and I like that [__] when he looks back
he's gonna think man that was bunny ass
[__] right and I'm happy and then he
comes busting out of the house by the
way you wanna know what his fight
clothes were
jean shorts
no shirt and a bandana
[Applause]
I was like where are you going Coachella
like when the [__]
and he comes running at me he throws a
punch I duck it I throw it over my hip
and Bam he lands on his back
you guys know that noise
with all the air s oh and I'm like oh I
got a couple minutes the wind has been
knocked out of him and the first time
the wind gets knocked out of you you
think you're dying right so I'm like oh
I got at least 15 minutes to [__] with
this guy 15 seconds or so right so I'm
like I'm gonna I've always got I was a
huge wrestling fan huge Randy the Macho
Man Savage man so I'm like I'm gonna
rain in the Macho Man so I started to
walk around I'm like oh yeah the Macho
Man I'm looking in the window at the
camera like
and then I got a couple more seconds I'm
gonna come off the top rope and I'm
gonna jump on him pull his leg up pin
him end of the wedding video Perfect
right so I go what you gonna do when the
Macho Man lands on you
that's the name is it for you know spur
of the moment that's all I had
I go to push when I push his leg slips
and when this leg slipped the disc
popped in my back and I landed right on
him and I knocked the wind out of him
again
and he's like get on let me get off of
me and I was like get out from under me
get out from under me
and we're both laying there like a
couple of wet mops in the front yard
30 seconds later he gets out from under
me walks inside and I'm laying in the
front
and uh
just laying there probably for like 10
minutes
and then the front door opens and I see
two feet walking out to me and I
recognize Sophie those are my wives
she walks out and she leans over me just
like this and she goes
how do you think that went
I said I think it went pretty well
and she said did it I said I won she
goes did you
she said all I know is that he's inside
drinking water and you're still laying
out here with your face in the dirt
he looks like the winner I go yeah but
we're going to cut the video off way
before that nobody's ever gonna see that
[__]
and I said babe
and I knew why she came out
she came out to tell me
that she was right and I was wrong and
she was
and I was gonna let I told her right off
the front I said look I know that you
were right and I was wrong and I'm so
sorry and I am the adult and he is the
child and I really just need to keep
that in mind like
this is how you parent your parent
together and I'm sorry we didn't do this
together and I should have listened to
you but thank you very much for coming
out to help me in and she said uh
I didn't come out here to help you in
she said I came out here to tell you
that the camera is still running in the
window
and I think I'm gonna start a little
video mom
because the sprinklers are set to come
on in three minutes
and As She's Walking Away I go babe I
don't think that's a good idea she turns
to me and she goes I'll let you know
when I have a bad idea
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you